hey Doc oh I'm a 35 year old and have a
physically demanding job I've been a
drywall ER for about 14 years work about
eight to ten hours a day when it comes
to working out I'm finding it really
hard to maintain discipline to continue
as it seemed as I it seems I burnout I
also have two boys under the age of four
so I sleep like you do man yeah I'm
wondering if I'm just being a [ __ ] and
need to push through the burnout or take
a different approach to working out when
I burn out my body just feels weird as
well as my head I tend to get depressed
and find it hard to even go to work just
throwing this out there for maybe some
tips to get over this so I can stay
focused and consistent Thanks cool
okay so hanging drywall hung drywall
before no yes no but yes okay I've been
in a dry wall hanging scenario scenario
yes but I didn't do the scene of the
drywall guy yeah that does not qualify
you do not get called for him if you've
seen it being hard I appreciate what
you're trying to say but that doesn't
work the drywall is hard work yes sir it
uses a bunch of different muscles into
your body
and of course when you get better at it
cuz I'm not good at it when I when I
hung dry when I hang drywall if I'm
doing a project I'm not good at it you
see someone that's good at like this guy
that's been hanging drywall for 14 years
he's a master yeah he's he's holding it
one hand slapping nails him he's your
drywall screw he's on stilts guys work
on stilts you ever seen that before no
no so good drywallers their own stilts
because they don't they're just boom
slapping it up there so but it's hard
you're doing you're basically doing a
clean can I ended up pull the the
drywall up you're pushing it up you're
using your grip strength on the drywall
then you're doing overhead presses
because you drywall ceilings
sometimes so and it's eight to ten hours
plus not to mention your you're bending
down picking stuff up all day so it's 8
to 10 hours of squats cleans and
overhead presses with grip work so
you're doing that 8 to 10
today so you're getting good physical
work throughout the day now look man if
you're that drained then first of all
let's check the diet let's make sure
that we're not on the jobsite and the
donut truck arrives and you're you're
going belly up to the donut truck with a
monster for Monster energy drinks like
to keep you going through the day that's
gonna hurt you so check the diet it's
the good thing is check the diet and
then if you have to just bring your food
don't let you know your bro that's gonna
run down to Mickey D's to grab lunch cuz
you didn't pack anything that's gonna
Jack you up so all that stuff will make
you feel weak and out of sorts and all
that
that being said still you're working
hard all day you're doing hard physical
labor all day you also I mean you can
see construction workers or drywall is
you see people that are do that hard
labor all day and they don't look like
they're in shape right mm-hmm
they're maybe they're fat maybe they're
just they don't look like they're in
shape well that's cuz their diet sucks
generally they're coming home and
they're getting on their their 12-pack
of beer and pizza
so get your diet make sure that's good
to go and then what I would do is and
I've worked construction before and/or
even make projects on my house where I'm
working all day long
remodeling pulling down drywall putting
up drywall demo in rooms whatever I
still do work out now what you're gonna
do though is do something that is going
to complement what you've done during
the day so you're getting some pretty
good strength for work at this point
you're getting you know you're getting
cleaned your grip work you're doing all
this this hard work all all throughout
the day so maybe what you need to do is
do some more cardiovascular at night or
maybe it's just like a really good
stretching routine because you got your
strength and you got your cardio dude
during the day like if I think about how
much I sweat when I'm working on a house
project my house I'm gonna fall athletic
sweat
so that means I'm working hard mmm so
find what can you do
that's gonna complement the the
conditioning that you're getting from
your actual labor and maybe in your case
it might just be like straight-up
mobility it might be straight-up
mobility like hey you're just doing some
good stretching you're doing some
mobility WOD
that's mobility workout of the day you
can go to that website they got really
good stuff on there to loosen up and
make sure you're staying limber because
another thing you find with construction
guys is they end up with some you know
with a bad back with a bad they get you
know tendinitis from swinging a hammer
all day or holding drift so you can get
those kind of use overuse injuries and
yeah so I would look at what you can do
that's gonna complement that also maybe
you feel like you maybe just need to do
some heavy lifting cuz you're lifting
something little all day you know
they're you lift and drywall all day so
you're getting some good endurance
muscular endurance but maybe just come
home and do do a couple sets of heavy
deadlifts or a couple sets of heavy
squats and that the other thing here is
like when we're on deployment when I was
back in the in when I was in the
military when we were on deployment we
wouldn't be doing workouts that are
gonna give you the four days of delayed
onset muscular soreness right you're not
gonna burn lockers you're not gonna put
you in the pain Locker and yeah yeah
we're hey I did squats yesterday Oh echo
just got shot I can't help but to tired
to sword broke can someone grab echo cuz
my legs are super sore my quads are
hurting from front squats yesterday yeah
yeah so that's not what I'm talking
about I'm talking about doing some
something that's heavy but it's quick
and you're not you know you're not going
crazy and doing so many sets that you're
gonna build up all kind of lactic acid
and make your legs all sore so maybe
it's something that but I would say
explore all that look what you can find
that's gonna make you that's gonna
compliment you what you do work and also
you could look at some jiu-jitsu mmm you
know look at some jiu-jitsu jiu-jitsu
although at first it's a crazy muscular
workout a full body workout like you've
never had before
yeah because you're resisting every part
of your movement and you'll be sore in
your entire body but then as you get
better at it you can relax more that
takes like a year year and a half maybe
even two years before you can really
start to relax the thing that's cool
about that for you is you got two kids
under the age of four so maybe in two or
three years
they're ready start training - now you
got will something to share with them a
little bit of jiu-jitsu so yeah don't
kill yourself find something that
complements your work and if that's just
stretching man just stretch yeah and
maybe you don't ice do it uh when I was
a team - team - used to do we used to
run all the time it was every day it was
like Oh Monday PT in a run Tuesday
swim in a run Wednesday obstacle course
and a run Thursday I forget what it was
and then Friday was a long run it was
like a 12 mile run or 10 mile run on
Fridays so what I would do is I would
get done with work on Friday or get done
with a PT on Friday and usually would be
like half half day frogman Friday
surf rock we have try to get some
pre-war no more going on guess what you
do on Friday afternoon in the dreams
you're gonna go you know get after it
with your boys in the bar on the bar
sure yeah frogmen Freddie frogman Friday
the N frogman Friday I know in a way
once September 11th happened so this is
pre September 11th frogman Fridays so we
get done with work and you know noon and
I would do Friday go down and hit my
squats and then so Friday I'd heal up
Saturday and Sunday back to work on
Sunday ready to rock and roll yeah so
maybe you hit just do a good workout on
Friday
yeah good hard work out on Friday heal
up over the weekend you're feeling good
Monday back in the game but yeah hard
labor
yeah requires something a little bit
different yeah then those of you that
are sitting at a desk looking at a
computer screen like echo Charles yes
sir yeah you can do a different kind of
workout when you do that all day for
sure you mentioned the diet I would say
with 99% certainty I would say I don't
know everybody right I understand that
99% certainty that if you have a good
diet not even a immaculate that a good
diet
and you're working drywall construction
moving as you know I used to be a mover
for a little bit yeah if you have a good
diet I mean you watched movie
because apparently your mind that
qualifies for you know just total
victory yeah anyway oh yeah I know
you're an actual yeah but good crap I
wasn't the best mover I was one anyway
that's that's another thing anyway
if you have a good diet and you're doing
this kind of work that is your workout
essentially and it's a long one it's
probably a harder workout than most
people's normal workouts you do and
that's the thing you're so right because
when you're working 810 hours a day
there's a lot of work to be done so your
lunch break is like dang this is I'm
gonna go to get some delicious you know
to this food truck right here or this
you know McDonald or wherever wherever
it's not you know you but you get a good
diet with this kind of stuff you
essentially have a great workout along
with a good diet you're gonna get
results just that yeah and in a way you
won't even really have to do these
supplemental workouts unless you have
different goals so if you're like okay
I'm just gonna do my work I'm gonna have
a good diet and then I stretch
afterwards which is such a good idea
when ya motion all day stretch you know
get all this but you'll be way better
you'll feel way better too and you'd be
surprised how much easier the work
becomes yeah and also maybe there's like
I said you need to look for what
complements it yeah so with drywall I
don't I don't know you know it's
probably not deadlifting cuz you're left
lifting stuff all day but maybe it's
just like some hardcore like ab core
strength that you're gonna work you're
gonna you know and that's gonna
strengthen your lower back it's gonna
offset all the pressure that you put on
your back all day so maybe it's that
maybe it's you know pull-ups because
you're not really pulling yourself up
yeah so so maybe you're doing two
workouts maybe you're doing like one
workout on Fridays you're doing abs and
pull-ups yeah and then during the week
you're doing a 20 minute stretch session
yeah to really make sure your hips are
opened up alright
of course like them guys from 10th
planet shits they're flexible that's
that you have to be you have to be able
to do Lotus to get your black belt from
Eddie Bravo there you go
I can't do the Lotus I can't get my
black belt from Eddie Bravo none
you can't know sorry bro I should be
able to do that at some point depends on
what you mean by should but yeah man
cool do the Lotus and work on that and
you know report back but you have a diet
thing I think the diet thing that's
gonna be 75 if not more per se or people
help you up yeah thank you they say you
don't sleep enough and how could how do
you not see don't eat crap yeah you
don't need as much sleep yeah check that
out give that one a try yeah and and
listen let's face it there's people can
be different with requirements you're
not really you know like if I said hey
Jocko you're in prison for I don't know
whatever and you have eight hours of
sleep yeah for eight hours we just know
how to pull it on a ship multiple times
three shipboard deployments as a seal
and when you're a seal on a ship you
have no job
you're like the guys that are the guys
that are in the regular Navy that are
driving the ship and maintaining the
ship and steering the ship and all that
they have a job we have no job yeah
and so what we we could either sleep eat
or lift and that's a we used to steal
stood for sleep eat and lift but some
guys would sleep a lot yeah I wouldn't
sleep a lot we had some guys that had
looks sleep disorders there was a guy
that slept for like twenty nine hours
but they need to wake up and stay awake
for 32 hours and then he'd go back to
bed so yeah it was kind of weird well he
cut his circadian rhythm was way off
yeah and then that happens to auto-ship
because you can stay inside the ship
with no Sun for free if you want to but
we used to we used to go out as much as
we could on the deck of the ship
yeah get a suntan no do pt sure that too
but yeah I think you um yeah you sleep
different and you know some eight-hour
and actually I've done this thing where
I got used to only getting like six six
and a half and it it started to work
like I said after that you know I didn't
like this I tried to go back to actually
only get six maybe seven no anyway
because the kids think anyway the diet I
think will I for real thing I believe
this effect 75% or more solution to the
whole
probably diet clean up the diet eat good
bring your lunch yeah stay away from the
Mickey D's yeah still with lawless